voici une autre bonne raison de réduire
sa consommation de sucre j'ai plus de
100000 française suivie depuis 2009 le
risque de développer un cancer a
augmenté de 18% avec la consommation
quotidienne de 100 millilitres de
boissons sucrées chez des personnes qui
n'ont pas d'autres facteurs de risque
par ailleurs en soit la consommation de
boissons sucrées à partir de là ce un
petit verre par jour là serait associée
à une augmentation du risque de cancer
même le petit verre de jus frais est au
banc des accusés
le problème ce sont les sucs liquide
parce que lorsque vous consommez feluy
la présence de fibres la présence de
polyphénols la présence de toutes sortes
d'autres molécules qui a dans le feu lui
à la lentille l'absorption des sucres
libres alors que quand vous consume un
jus de fruit
l'aspect liquide fait que la montée de
la glycémie plus rapide
le docteur en biochimie richard béliveau
estime que l'étude épidémiologique
publiée dans le british medical jolo est
solide il va falloir aller plus loin
parce qu'on sait c'est que le sucre en
général vont est une cause d'excès de
poids et l'excès de poids lui est une
cause confirmé justement de risque de
cancer aujourd'hui la science est plus
forte que les études sont les d'intérêt
et la baisse se multiplient les
expériences on devrait avoir de plus en
plus des études de ce type lola apparaît
dans les prochaines années
déjà je prends pas de jus de fruit et
que pour des raisons personnelles ses
trousses créer des tâches parallèles à
faire notre dépendance aux cieux
l'omniprésent du sud d'un produit
industriellement transformé et le
développement du cancer du poumon des
autres cancers à ceci la consommation de
cigarettes dans les années 50 près de la
moitié des cancers sont liés aux
habitudes de vie donc ils pourraient
être évités en faisant plus d'activité
physique en cessant de fumer et en
mangeant mieux
désormais cela voudrait dire aussi en
buvant moins de boissons sucrées ici
anne louise despatie radio-canada à
montréal